[Music]
delicious slow braised stuffed lamb
breast
one of the secrets to slow cooking is to
be robust and really get stuck in big
bold flavors work really well so don't
be precious this is gutsy cooking at its
absolute best
these are lamb breasts a beautiful cheap
cut and it's sort of tucked alongside
the rib they've been boned out the skin
has been taken off i'm going to roll
them stuff them and braise them braising
simply means cooking in liquid on a low
heat making the meat divinely tender now
open them up and give them a really good
season
season them both sides inside and out
really important
it doesn't look like a real weighty
dense cut of meat but once it's
beautifully slow braised it's just like
melting lamb it's incredible
i'm gonna season the breasts with some
dried oregano
put a heat in there
some chili flakes
[Music]
lemon zest
put some amazing
salted anchovies in there now they
almost melt inside the lamb
so the balance of flavors
work beautifully
now pull it down
towards you
and roll that nice and tightly
that's what i'm looking for
string
i just need to tie them
three times one at each end and one in
the middle
i fell in love with this dish years ago
when i first started working in paris
because we had all the lamin from the
pyrenees
the nice thing is they can be done the
day before
pan on olive oil in
get their oil nice and hot
lamb in
really important to get
some nice color on there
whilst they're browning
slice the onion
the lamb's gonna be cooking for two and
a half hours so don't slice the onions
too thinly otherwise they'll burn garlic
and leave whole
got a color on them look at that
beautiful
take them out
onions in and garlic straight in lovely
that's the secret about slow braising
you never change pans
why
all the goodness
is in that one pan
a few chili seeds in there
oregano
nice pinch
a little bit of lemon in there i'm gonna
do the onions what i did to the lamb
[Music]
next my capers
fry them off
get them exploding the bottom of the pan
they get nice and crispy
next my black olives
now
white wine
bring that up to the boil
deglazing the pan as well
i rinse in the bottom of that pan
and now the flavour in there it's just
extraordinary
now
where that tomatoes
[Music]
puncher
those plum tomatoes
then simply place the lamb breast back
in the pot and remember to taste
[Music]
that's nice
[Music]
lid on
into the oven
170
two
two and a half hours and forget about it
[Music]
whoa
beautiful
all that has reduced down to this
amazing nice
tomato sauce and the lamb
has kept its color look at that it's
braised beautifully
very carefully
get your little bits there slice
off pull off the little bits of string
this is why i get really excited
the secret is not to slice it too thinly
look at that
i can smell the lemon
it's hard to believe when you slice
through the center there that that is a
very cheap
cut of meat i'm salivating
i love this i mean it's just incredible
pick up the tomatoes and the olives and
the onions
an amazing
rich sauce
take
your lamb sort of just
sit it on
it looks incredible
and that for me
is why chefs get so excited with
cheap cuts because the end results are
incredible
delicious breast of lamb
with lemon anchovies chili and oregano
a devilishly indulgent dessert
nothing beats a great cake a sort of a
show-off trophy for party food so i'm
going to make the most amazing
flowerless chocolate cake but with a
twist
first thing first make the caramel
flatten the sugar never stir a caramel
rule number one now keep the pan nice
and flat
i'm gonna flavor this caramel with a
little bit of mint give it a little chop
sprinkle that into the caramel
don't get the caramel too dark just nice
and light
a little teaspoon of oil onto the tray
and rub that in
and then pour out
your caramel if i was making a caramel
sauce then i'd put butter and cream into
the caramel but i want this nice minted
brittle running through my cake
whilst the caramel cools down on the
tray i'm gonna make my cake
first melt good quality dark chocolate
in a bain-marie
heating it directly in the pan would
destroy the cocoa fats always in a bowl
over boiling water
in a mixing bowl sugar two whole eggs
and three egg yolks
whisk until beautifully light and creamy
and the color changes to a light yellow
the more you mix the eggs and the sugar
the lighter that texture in the center
of the chocolate cake
next melt some butter into your warm
dark chocolate and stir was that really
nice sheen
velvety rich and tasting amazing add
that to your sugar and your eggs
now give that a really good mix
now when you're making flourless
desserts it really is important to work
harder incorporating the air especially
with the yolks and the sugar that
natural height needs to take place at
the beginning look at that looks like
the perfect chocolate ganache
then separate four egg whites into a
bowl
[Music]
now
make sure you've got two-thirds of the
way there with your whites and then just
sprinkle in
your sugar it's almost like a meringue
and the firmer you make these now the
more it will elevate your cake in the
oven
[Music]
that's what you call a stiff peak
in with the whites
before i start mixing that i'm gonna get
my caramel
just start
breaking that up
it's like glass sheets of glass
beautiful
save some of your minty caramel shards
for decoration and use a rolling pin to
break up the rest into small pieces
sprinkle that in
so as we start to slice that chocolate
cake you'll come across that nice crunch
take your cake tin
make sure it's lined
with the greaseproof paper
on the bottom nicely greased
pour this in
a few sharp taps on a hard surface will
rid your cake mixture of any air pockets
that could create holes in your cake
sit that in the oven
180.
after 35 minutes my chocolate mint cake
is cooked and whilst it cools down i can
whip up a peppermint cream topping
[Music]
add sifted icing sugar and a few drops
of peppermint extract to double cream
and whisk until it's just holding its
shape
your minty cream on top of the cake
leaving a small border free to make it
easier to cut
for a cake that can't fail to attract
attention at your party scatter over the
remaining caramel mint shards
we've got aromatic lean lamb chops with
char grilled broccoli and burger wheat
salad for dessert it's healthy mango
sundae
holly
[Music]
then i can help daddy with the dessert
yes please and the lamb cutlets now
we all know that you love desserts yeah
yeah we'll do a little
yogurt parfait with some macerated
fruits
so the first thing i'd like you to do is
take a tablespoon
of icing sugar dust that over the fruits
good
now sad enough that's perfect daddy
thank you
zest the orange over the fruits and
what's going to happen now is going to
start to sort of marinate i'm going to
put some basil in there
that'll make it really flavoursome
fresh basil in
and then i'm going to give that a little
mix up
i'm going to squeeze
some fresh orange juice in there
nice and gently okay
how gorgeous do those berries look now
okay so we just leave them just marinate
okay and that's what we call
macerated berries
now for the mango sundae right mangoes
in place
i love mangoes
nice
now they're naturally sweet okay
one
oh
that smells incredible
now
how fresh
does that smell very no you love art
right yeah i do so you're gonna put
these together so a nice little dollop
of mango at the bottom nice and slowly
once each glass has a layer of mango
puree at the bottom
spoon over a layer of thick natural
yogurt and alternate until the glass is
full
well done now it's yummy from there you
get your berries
you sit your berries on top
they taste so fresh
but now they've been marinated and the
berries have been slightly macerated and
then finally look
get your icing sugar and just tap
on top
they
look it's beautiful
now
they sit in the fridge to get nice
and chilled okay
so
if i take three
and promise not to sneeze
and you take one open the fridge door
good job
desserts chilling in the fridge now for
the super simple main course to go with
the aromatic lamb chops a tasty char
grill broccoli and bulgur wheat salad
to cook the bulgur wheat just simmer
until tender then drain
to give the broccoli a char grilled
flavor simply cook with salt in a hot
dry pan until smoky and tender
for a quick and easy aromatic dressing
mixed together harissa paste with either
buttermilk or creme fraiche and add
chopped mint simple as that
to serve thoroughly dress your broccoli
and burger wheat and finish with more
fresh mint leaves
dessert ready and salad's done now for
the aromatic grilled lamb chops
how much do you love lamb holes a lot a
lot on a scale of one to ten
ten okay these lamb chops are gonna be
delicious first i'm gonna marinate them
i'll start putting the spices in yeah
first one
coriander coriander good so a teaspoon
of coriander seeds in a little touch of
what's that human human well done cumin
in
one of daddy's favorites
turmeric chew me a teaspoon of that in
there
now
a little touch
of salt
and then i want you to start grinding
that down while i get the ginger and the
garlic
give that a nice little mix
please for daddy
that looks amazing after that get the
garlic lay it flat
and look
it almost purees the garlic so we get a
nice paste
see underneath sorry about dirting your
nails
it's okay
i just smell like garlic now nothing
wrong with that
the more you smell of garlic
the less the boys are gonna date you
sorry
right now the ginger
makes it sort of
spicy
and fruity now get the ginger and do
exactly the same with the ginger when
you grate it like this it turns into the
most amazing
ginger puree off your diet
come on holly put some muscle into it
good girl
nice see all that there you got the back
of the knife
now i'm going to drizzle some olive oil
in there okay and you bring that
together
as a paste for daddy there you go
stuck on no it'll come off
nice
good girl
now that smells incredible that
is a delicious paste
so i'm gonna tip
all that marinade on
to the lamb
and then i want you to rub it all in to
those lamb chops
then we go get your hands in there my
girl
come on holes
so look
you get them in there then you rub
all that marinade
the flavor inside these chops come on
holly that's right come on
your jumper's fine
just
smell that
nice fresh
and the earlier you do this
the better
the turmeric is starting to stain
the lamb chops they're not even cooked
yet yet they smell delicious yeah
what are you like honestly oh my nails
oh my nails
delicious after marinating from 10
minutes to overnight but if you can't
wait to get your hands on them you can
grill the chops strain away gas nice and
high and grilling them
it's gonna make them slightly healthier
so
lamb on
first one
in
we'll slide that in
alongside is that so you sit more in the
pan that's right what i want to do is
get those really nice
grill marks on there
[Music]
see
come on
[Music]
now we're going to cook them
three sides
one side up flip it and then on the back
see this bit here yeah i'm gonna grill
it on there as well
[Music]
now if you could get the yogurt out of
the fridge please daddy
nice
some fresh mint
i want you to pick
the mint
please and give it a little chop and mix
it in with the yogurt smells amazing
doesn't it
so yogurt
in
chop up
the mint please
have a look
at the color
of the lamb
that was
beautiful
that was so nice does it
how nice
are they
they smell incredible grilling them this
way they cook so much quicker
okay it's a lot healthier
smell those
beautiful excited yes very
good
eric and megan will like those i hope so
[Music]
see what i'm doing i'm standing the
chopped up yeah
we're not gonna dry out this way
is that chopped enough try a bit more
that's fine and then mix it
into yogurt please darling this isn't
too hard is it dad not a salmon
how would you know when they're done
nice and pink three and a half to four
minutes each side
medium
six minutes well done
eight or nine minutes
how would you like your landmark
medium rare that's what i always go for
a lamb cutlet at his best
will be medium red off with the gas
okay
it's got a lovely
lovely flavor
okay
look at that
wow
i'm in heaven
i'll carry the lamb
and the yogurt if you get the bowl of
wheat and the broccoli they're done that
smells incredible it really does
fast and easy to make packed with
goodness and utterly delicious with a
bit of kitchen know-how you have my
ultimate healthy dinner on the table in
just 30 minutes